and the truth will deliver you from
[Music]
procrastination and laziness and the
downward spiral that comes with a lack
of discipline the most inspired
motivated person wins nah not really
it's the person who can work on the
day's they're not inspired and motivated
it's what do you do when you're not
feeling great
you gotta get sick and tired of defeat
aren't you tired of getting beat aren't
you tired of being on the losing end
what's that believed nation in seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the belief life
series too once a week tackle topics
that are outside the war'll of just
hardcore entrepreneurship and business
so to help you live your best belief
life today we're gonna look at how you
can end procrastination joy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one deal with stress with Mel Robbins
I'm about to change your life because
this piece of research changed mine
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
the people that write to us the most
that struggle with procrastinating PhD
students engineers entrepreneurs people
that have a lot on their plate that have
a lot of things that they need to juggle
and that are analytical and thinkers by
nature procrastination is a form of
stress relief
what are you stressed about
bingo and it makes you a fat doesn't it
yeah how many of you can relate to that
she said that what's stressing her out
is she wants to retire she hasn't saved
up enough money what's really stressing
you out is finances and money and the
fear that you have what happens when you
struggle with procrastinating and thank
you for being so honest there's if it
stresses you out maybe you feel the same
way and we felt that way I know exactly
what you're talking about you carry
around this dark cloud because you don't
think you're gonna make it you're
stressed about money all the time or
maybe your mom's health is declining and
it really stresses you out or maybe your
best friends are going through a divorce
or you're going through a divorce and
that really stresses you out and so you
walk around with this big-ass thing on
your shoulders all the time and then you
walk into work and you sit down and
you've got a list of phone calls to make
which requires your prefrontal cortex
and your prefrontal cortex looks at the
list and it's like oh my god you want me
to make 15 phone calls I've been worried
about the money all day can we just look
at cat videos I need a break
and next thing you know two hours is
gone you've been online shopping even
looking at cat videos and then of course
you look at the 15 phone calls you're
like I didn't make him I didn't make him
I didn't make the research on
procrastination is undeniable it's black
and white
number one all of you that procrastinate
procrastination is not the issue it's
stress you're procrastinating to give
yourself a little break at work it's
sort of like taking a smoking break
almost you know you're just taking a
break so number one because you're all
stressed out and procrastinators are
very hard on yourselves this is gonna
sound super stupid but you got to
forgive yourself you have got to
actually have a talk with yourself where
where you feel yourself starting
procrastinate you go look you know I
really screwed up I know I'm in a mess
financially I forgive myself I'm just
gonna do the best that I can so you have
to address the thing that's underneath
it so that's self-awareness of knowing
oh my god here's that stress again about
finances screwing me over and preventing
me from doing the small things that will
actually fix my finances second thing
that you're gonna do procrastination is
a habit right you get triggered by
stress the habit is to procrastinate so
when you get triggered by
Dress your new habit is oh there's my
stress again I'm gonna actually tell
myself okay you've done the best you can
it's okay we're gonna do a little bit
today you're gonna create what we call
starting ritual a starting ritual is
something that pushes you to start the
best one on the planet the five-second
rule so you've said okay there's my
stress again I forget myself now we're
gonna five four three two one
I want you to only work for five minutes
that's it five minutes make phone calls
for five minutes here's what we know
based on the research 80% of you will
keep going
the trick is starting you see I want to
break the connection between the trigger
which is stress and the response which
is procrastination and whenever you feel
stressed which is normal you have a
choice here's that gap in five seconds
flat
the habit of procrastinating and beating
yourself up will take over or you can
close the gap five four three two one
and you can make a different choice I'm
just gonna get started I'm just gonna be
okay with where I'm at and I'm just
gonna get started got it good
rule number two cast out the lies with
jockle willing the chronic excuse maker
how do you stop making excuses this is
actually pretty simple and I said it the
other day and you have to realize you
have to know you have to accept that all
your excuses are lies they are lies all
of them think about the things that you
tell yourself the lies you used to
rationalize taking the easy road taking
the easy road and leaving discipline
behind think about them you don't have
time that's a lie you don't have support
that's a lie you don't have the
equipment or the gear lies you don't you
don't know the best way who cares that's
a lie or you're too old or you're too
young of course you're too old or too
why and there's you're too busy sure you
are that's high and you're too tired or
you're too sore or you're just plain not
feeling it lies lies lies and the list
goes on and on and on
and it doesn't stop if you don't make it
stop so recognize recognize the excuses
are not valid
they aren't they're trumped up they're
conjured up they're fabricated their
lies and how do you stop the lies you
stop the lies with the truth the truth
the truth will set you free the truth
will stand and the truth will deliver
you from procrastination and laziness
and the downward spiral that comes with
a lack of discipline so don't believe
the lies believe the truth and the truth
is you have time you have the skill you
have the knowledge and the support and
the willpower and the discipline to get
it done so cast out the lies burn them
down and listen to the truth then live
the truth and go out and get it done
rule number three have a vision with
Jordan B Peterson one of the things that
can help you stop procrastinating well
let's say two things I refer to them at
the end of my talk one is God really
nicely developed this
of heaven it's like okay here's what you
need to know how would your life be what
would it be like if it was really good
and I don't don't get primitive about
that it's not like you know naked
supermodels on a yacht they're too
skinny anyways anyways you know what I
mean it's like yeah yeah that's I get it
but it's it's it's it's not a gap pace
eh so it's it's not sophisticated enough
to be self-sustaining it's a stupid
vision and if you pursue it it's you're
just gonna be on a sinking yacht with
like anorexics or something like that so
you need a vision you need a vision of
what your life would be like if it was
just the way it should be if it was best
for you and if you were taking care of
yourself with this thing that you kind
of described as parental love this is a
really good way of thinking about it
because it's nice and concrete so what
would be best for you three to five
years down the road if you were really
taking care of yourself like you were
someone that you thought should be
around and people are very ambivalent
about whether they should be around so
this is a lot harder than you think
so you need that vision and then what
you also need is a vision of what your
life would be like if you let yourself
deteriorate in precisely the foolish
ways that you know that you would
deteriorate if you let yourself go and
that's contemplation too it's like okay
if I let myself go where would I end up
and first of all this is kind of a
shadow realization from union
perspective it's like first of all you
could let yourself go
second of all you already know exactly
how you do it if you did do it and third
with a little imagination you can
conjure up exactly what that would be
like not only for you but for your
family and for the broader social
community and that would be the whole
bloody catastrophe including all the
malevolence that would go along with
your deterioration and so on and so then
you've got these stark choices before
you one is a gap a oriented
equilibration for lack of a better
technical phrase and the other is
something that more closely approximate
hell approximates health and people even
think because if you sink low enough not
only do you sink that low but you are
absolutely motivated
drag people down there with you and it's
a nasty nasty state of affairs and so if
you're really terrified of that like you
should be because you've drawn the
causal connections and you're really
attracted by the other then when you sit
down and you don't do what you're doing
what you're supposed to be doing you
don't get to say well it doesn't matter
and that's the salience landscape issue
it's like no no no the little voice in
the back of your head that says it
matters it sees those outcomes just down
into the future and it's telling you
that it matters and if you would like
the positive outcome over the negative
outcome which is like I said your
constant choice you bloody well better
sit down and do what you're supposed to
and so that's really helpful that'll I
think you know what is it fear of God is
the beginning of wisdom it's like yes
that's absolutely right and the role of
things like anxiety and terror in
promoting proper development well are
often under address because we think of
those things as our enemies it's like
they're they're at your enemies if you
if they're working against you but
they're pretty powerful monsters on your
side if you've got the Mauri nted
properly rule number four create an
environment of total focus with Robin
Sharma your environment is so important
and if you look at be performers or see
producers they really don't pay a lot of
tension to their environment and so they
get very distracted there's lots of
noises their phones are going off maybe
there's news in the background maybe
there's messy environments all around
them maybe there's toxic people what I'm
suggesting to you is the second piece of
technology to really 100 times your
productivity is this install
environments of type bubbles of total
focus the way I run my work life on
certain days
I am very hard to reach and I challenge
you with great love and respect be very
hard to reach during key times of your
week I mean I see a lot of people and
it's not judging them it's just
observing them every time their phone
rings they check it or they have you
know these loud notifications so they're
constantly being distracted and we know
what the research says the research says
we spend 2.1
hours a day in distraction we spent and
it takes 21 minutes to refocus your
focus after you've been distracted so if
you are being distracted by
notifications checking your phone
checking your Twitter feed checking your
Facebook feed looking on Instagram
checking all the different platforms
that is going to destroy your focus so
the second piece of Technology's create
these tight bubbles of total focus and
the way I do it is I have certain days
that I label as creative days and on
those creative days I actually go device
free and on those days I'm very hard to
find and on those days I'm in total
solitude and on those days I go to
certain places I called them my Menlo
labs just like Edison had his Menlo lab
and these places are very minimalist and
there's no one there and that's where I
do my best work so install these tight
bubbles of total focus and create these
Menlo labs where you're sorry you're
completely distraction free and then you
will find your brain will drop from the
beta state into the alpha state where
you will do your best work and get your
best ideas rule number five rely on your
habits with Ed Milan here's the thing I
get asked all the time how did you stay
motivated all the time people ask me
that all the time and the answer is I
did it and neither did you to become
successful the separator in life is
really important you'll think the most
inspired motivated person wins not not
really it's the person who can work on
the day's they're not inspired and
motivated it's what do you do when
you're not feeling great what do you do
when it's not your best day how do you
do that carries you through is rituals
and habits so when you're fatigued when
you're tired when you're under pressure
you react reflexively and so successful
people rely on habits and rituals not
just their inspiration and motivation
level of course we're both professionals
and being motivated and inspired but
that's not every day every minute and so
what do I do I work on the days because
my habits and rituals carry me through
and so for me here's how I look at my
life in my day if I can control the
first 30 minutes of my day and the last
30 minutes of my day I have a whole lot
better
of the middle of my day being controlled
and so I'm a freak about the first 30
minutes of every day it's really about
the first 45 minutes and I'm obsessive
about the last 45 minutes of every
single day
that gives me some illusion in my mind
and measure of control the other thing
it does it delivers to me habits and
rituals that serve me that I do every
day that are consistent it gives me
comfort in stormy times that ocean out
there is raging at the top right now
right the waves are crashing at the
bottom of that ocean it's completely
calm at the bottom of that ocean is the
habitual part of the water right it's
the if the part of the war that stays
the most consistent that's why it's so
calm okay
so when you see someone out of control
their emotions are up and down all the
time this is someone who is without
rituals and habits successful people
have those and so they do and so it
keeps me calm it keeps me comfortable
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus clip is get up with
Eric Thomas you better hear what I'm
telling you my final one you got to get
sick and tired of defeat aren't you
tired of getting beat aren't you tired
of being on the losing end I want you to
know what it feels like to finish
something I can't explain to y'all my
life has gone to a whole other level
when I finished that four-year degree
when I finished that master's degree
when I finished my book can I explain
you how my life has changed
in just one month the fact that the
people know I'm finished with the book
I'm getting engagements and I never got
before I got companies calling me that
never called me before not because I
finished the book but because I finished
something they see me as a person that
follows through and I want you to know
what I used to feel defeat it felt bad
but there's a total different feeling
when you accomplish stuff you've got a
different level of credibility from
people people see you different people
will they do things for you that they've
never done before people you have
credibility that you never had before
and so I encourage you I encourage you
follow through finish your history boy
et listen to me hard I told you before
I told you the last episode when my aunt
died ELISA told me I just buried my aunt
all right I just buried my aunt a couple
days ago but sometimes in life you got a
more you got it's the time of season for
all but then you got to get up your wife
died get up you got a divorce
get up you fail the test get up you got
kicked out of college on academic
probation get up get up right forget the
past because that's exactly what it is
to pass and make the rest of your life
the best of your life
now I've got a really special bonus
message with Cindy trim on how to focus
on your goals that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know whose message
resonated with you more Mel Robbins or
Eric Thomas let me know leaving the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
stop procrastinating focus on your goals
when you focus on what you want what you
don't want or automatically leaves your
life don't focus on eliminating anything
focus on creating what you want so
you're either gonna spend all your
energies eliminating what you don't want
or you spend your energies creating what
you want
we all have alibis we're all busy busy
doing what I'm gonna challenge you stay
focus on your goals and if you don't
have goals write your goals one of the
greatest enemies of fulfillment of
purpose is procrastination and broken
focus if you start now and you say 365
days from today's date this is what I
want to accomplish and you do one a day
poll said focus this one thing I do I'm
focusing you do one a day at the end of
one year you will have made 365 steps
towards fulfillment of purpose who is
not going to be successful at the end of
their life who's not going to be
prosperous at the end of their life if
they could fulfill that if you tell
yourself a story long enough you still
have to believe it don't you believe it
you act like I have Tulsa what a whale
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident
it's absolutely
free check out the link in description
below to get access